et voilà pour ce documentaire de marché
de la ferrari français par le sang versé
histoire d'une loi alors bien sûr on va
revenir sur ce documentaire sur les
questions qu'ils soulèvent et on va
s'intéresser à la légion a ses codes ses
règles à son esprit et tout en se
demandant si aujourd'hui à l'époque
d'une armée moderne professionnaliser et
bien l'existence de ce corps s'il s'agit
de l'accord se justifie toujours autant
voilà pour parler de tout cela est bien
le général christophe de saint-chamas
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes le
commandant de la légion depuis septembre
c'est pas très longtemps mais c'est
encore que vous connaissez depuis
longtemps parce que vous avez fait
plusieurs séjours ses étudiants on parle
pas de ces jours-ci qu'on peut dire
c'est glamour on va passer des vacances
à légion jean dominique merchet vous
êtes journaliste vous êtes le directeur
adjoint de la rédaction de marianne et
vous êtes un grand spécialiste des
questions défense vous avez un blog qui
s'appelle secret défense et qui fait
paraît-il autorité dans le monde
militaire il paraît qu'on s'y réfèrent
facilement en face vous le sénateur
apparenté socialiste jacques berthou
merci d'être là vous vous êtes aussi un
passionné des questions de défense
puisque vous êtes membre de la
commission des affaires étrangères de
défense et les forces armées et vous
avez un petit peu combattu si je puis
dire aux côtés de la légion l'algérie
j'ai fait la guerre d'algérie bien
entendu et j'étais proximité de
de la légion puisque mon unité était à
quelques kilomètres de sidi bel abbès et
nous avions donc savourer les lire ça
crée des liens et fréquentaient les
mêmes les mêmes bars ton petit russie
voilà comment savez vous marchez la
sphère où vous êtes donc roumaine
d'origine alors je me demandais pourquoi
vous aviez fait ce film sur la légion à
romy que vous avez épousé un légionnaire
en vie d'avant oui mais dans l'ordre et
des fêtes j'ai d'abord fait un reportage
sur la légion étrangère et j'ai posé
après un légionnaire donc on arrive à en
france j'étais correspondant pour la
télévision publique roumaine
j'ai fait un documentaire pour la
télévision aux mains sur la légion
étrangère
c'était en 2002 on était très intéressé
à l'époque comment on peut assurer notre
défense parce qu'on n'était pas encore
membre de l'otan et donc on se posait la
question si la légion étrangère peut
être un modèle pour la retraite une
question qu'on avait en roumanie on se
faisait dire et si la légion pour un
modèle pour qu'on avance enfin sur la
question de la défense européen d'accord
donc là vous avez trouvé votre mari
c'est pas plus mal
un légionnaire qui sent bon le sable
chaud que ce qu'imaginent ce pourquoi
j'ai choisi ce thème du sang versé qui
là pour le coup est calme assez
spécifique cette loi l'histoire de cette
loi comme elle est adoptée comment on a
bataillé sur scène quoi ça a été un
grand bataille législative si vous
voulez mais tout le monde l'a votée à la
fin c'est une loi qui a été votée à
l'unanimité ce qui est assez rare il ya
toujours des grands bagarre à
l'assemblée au sénat toutes les lois
sont votées dans la passion si vous
voulez mais cette loi finalement voté à
l'unanimité et pourquoi c'est parce que
à toute cette histoire de rage et
étrangers qui est passionnante qui est
fascinant qui continue de fasciner moi
ça me fascine encore même si je connais
jeu qu'on est beau bien même très bien
la légion étrangère
mais il ya aussi tout ce débat sur
l'intégration et je pense que
l'intégration des légionnaires c'est un
modèle d'intégration ça se passe
généralement bien alors on va écouter un
petit peu ce que dit dans votre
documentaire marius novakovski un kit à
légionnaires qui a été blessé et qui
nous dire qui peut ce que veut dire que
l'engagement combat quand on est
légionnaires et étrangers
quelque chose qui se passe dans les
moments comme ça on prend conscience
qu'elle on a servi à un pays avec des
armes et tombent les cèpes
pour moi ça ça crée un lien je ne sais
pas ça ça m'a dit que maintenant ces
moments je vais finir ma vie pour cette
parole de légionnaires blessés au combat
on a quelquefois du mal à comprendre
l'engagement
déjà quand on est civil on se dit bon un
militaire comment est ce qu'on veut on
choisit éventuellement de données ou
sacrifier sa vie ne s'est pas le but
premier pour la patrie mais là c'est pas
la patrie lorsqu'elle s'y fait qu'il
sent verger type là ce qui fait qu'un
étranger s'engage dans la légion
étrangère c'est la france c'est à dire
que 250 pays dans le monde
il ya des gens qui ont entendu parler de
la france qui ont rêvé de la france qui
ont vu briller la france et qui ont pris
leur vélo pour venir du land bator qui
sont venus de chine qui sont de partout
les gens que vous nous racontez là parce
qu'il verra bien d'autres intérêts plus
concret a alors mai mais bien sûr c'est
ainsi il ya il y a et il y a d'abord
autant de raisons de venir la légion
étrangère qu'il y a deux légionnaires
chacun sa raison sa motivation
mais là cette cette entité de la légion
étrangère est à mes yeux n'est pas
transposable ailleurs c'est parce que
c'est la france
quand je les vois arriver vous dites là
mais ils le disent ils le formalise ils
viennent leur disant c'est la france en
mai près de notre ville pour la fronde
des combats extérieur comme ça mais
d'avant quand ils arrivent ils le disent
ils arrivent ce qu'ils veulent c'est
celle accueille donc y sont accueillis
et ses sondes ensuite on une fois qu'on
les a accueillis c'est dans les les
règles de vie dans l'objectif qui est le
mien la mission que j'ai qui est de
fédérer ses 150 culture ensemble pour
créer une communauté qui s'appelle aller
jusqu'à 150 nationalités dans ce port de
environ 16 milles hommes voilà c'est le
sénateur vous qu'ils avaient côtoyé on
disait dans le désert algérien
vous les voyez comment comme des types
qui sont là comme à pau comme des
mercenaires ou comme des biens du clan
vraiment attaché à la france pas du tout
ils sont attachés à un france y sont
attachées aussi à cette image
deux des équipes ils viennent ils ont
besoin pour certains d'entre eux de
retrouver notre motivation dans leur vie
ce que j'avais connu donc ça remonte
quand même un certain nombre d'années et
qu' il est il trouvait si vous voulez
parce que la légion étrangère est une
image est une histoire qui a largement
dépassé nos frontières et qui pour sa
certain nombre de personnes sert
d'exemple et essaye de se revenir si
vous voulez défendre nos couleurs
ils essaient aussi de se reconstruire au
même les motivations jeu parce que vous
avez beaucoup fréquenté de légionnaires
oui je je crois que la légion étrangère
c'est un mythe
au niveau mondial c'est vraiment une
unité qui fait rêver dans le monde
entier les gens au vide en est parce que
il n'y a pas beaucoup de troupes comme
ça en fait qu'à lacunes comme ça mais en
tout cas c'est une unité où l'on peut
aller en étant de n'importe quelle
nationalité ça peut vous voyez dans les
trucs très mythique vous avez les les
marines américains sauf que si vous
n'êtes pas résidents des états unis vous
ne pouvez pas vous engager dans les
marines américains donc le les mômes
quelque part dans le monde qui souffrent
du pays
leur rêve pas besoin dans un pays qui
sont je vais citer ice au guatemala ou
ou au laos
bon dit peuvent s'engager dans leur
armée ils savent quand même qu'en
s'engageant dans l'armée ils n'auront
ils vont pas connaître la vie et les
capacités opérationnelles qui
connaîtrait s'ils viennent dans la
légion étrangère parce que c'est
vraiment une armée qui fait rêver le
monde entier
quand la légion on va oser les
américains sont baba devant la légion
donc si vous voulez aujourd'hui assure
encore aujourd'hui
donc si vous voulez vous avez comme
cette chose extrêmement mythique et
alors est ce qu ils viennent pour la
france où est-ce qu'ils viennent pour la
légion moi j'ai plutôt tendance à penser
qu'ils viennent pour la légion
d'ailleurs la légion le dis en elle même
il puisque le réunionnais guillot patria
nostra la légion est notre batterie voix
et donc ça c'est le c'est l'adage de la
légion et cette légion est au service de
la france c'est une armée française et
française ça il ya aucun doute ils
servent elles
comme les autres militaires mais quand
même l'attrait de cette unité d'élite
unique au monde
je pense que c'est comme ça qui est
déterminant qu'est ce qu'il fait pour
vous envie vous donne un exemple récent
lorsque on nous avons enterré le caporal
franco vic serbe morts en afghanistan
son père et a dit au ministre merci pour
l'honneur que vous faites à mon fils son
rêve d'enfant c'était d'être
légionnaires son surnom dans la famille
c'était on sait pas comment ça dit le
légionnaire
donc c'est un gamin qui a grandi avec un
rêve devenir légionnaires et même ses
parents dans l'épreuve venait s'incliner
et respecter le choix de leur fils c'est
quand même c'est quand même fabuleux
alors on va écouter un petit peu ce que
disait claude goasguen justement lors du
débat à l'assemblée sur ce texte de loi
sur le sang versé où il semble s étonné
lui-même de ce que ce soit pas une
évidence que de règles récupère de
d'acquérir l'un de ces françaises quand
on a on s'est sacrifié pour la patrie
française le texte qu'on nous propose et
qu'on nous propose avec combien de
débats n'est pas un texte d'automaticité
monsieur sarr ni de plein droit
j'étais persuadée jusqu'à ce qu'éclate
la polémique il y a quelques semaines
dans la presse que quand on servait dans
la région et bien au bout d'un certain
nombre d'années il était normal que la
nation reconnaissent le service rendu
par le sang versé et accorde
automatiquement la nationalité aux
légionnaires je leur envoyais quand même
pas mal de droit à postuler à cet
honneur de la nation et je me suis
aperçu comme beaucoup de français croyez
moi qui ce n'était pas le cas
j'ai vu qu'en réalité des dossiers était
embouteillée dans des administrations
dans les fonctionnaires estimable
n'avait sans doute jamais été sur un
théâtre d'opérations alors on a vu votre
documentaire on a un petit peu de mal à
comprendre quand même ce qui a bloqué
qu'est ce qui a bloqué dans cette
histoire qui concerne somme toute
heureusement assez peu de gens et qui
paraît là aussi assez évidente qu est ce
qui a bloqué je pense que c'est
simplement comme le disait le député
goasguen c'est simplement et lourdeurs
administratives le feu nos fonds peut
pas dire que positive d'ailleurs non je
pense que personne ne s'en était jamais
soucié parce que vous savez voilà on
était donc voilà on consomme
la france a consommé entre guillemets
beaucoup de légionnaires au cours de son
histoire dans toutes ces guerres y
compris ses guerres coloniales et puis
on sent manquait un peu et c'est vrai
que dans les années 90 alors que l'armée
française s'est professionnalisé donc
elle s'est rapprochée au fond d'un
modèle d'armée de professionnels et un
rapport différent par rapport aux
sacrifices
vous avez quand vous aviez 50 morts
pendant la guerre d'algérie au fond tout
le monde s'en moquer vous avez
aujourd'hui un mort en afghanistan ça
fait la une des journaux
donc il ya une sensibilité différente à
ces questions et puis un jour
effectivement quelqu'un s'est dit mais
c'est vrai qu'il faudrait quand même
qu'on fasse quelque chose
et là tout le monde a dit à l'unanimité
oui faisons quelque chose à la fin on a
comme l'impression en regardant votre
documentaire qu'à un moment donné parce
que il y avait commis tant ce politique
un débat sur l'immigration je sais pas
trop quoi ou sur la naturalisation que
madame guigou avait été assez réticentes
à accorder ce droit là par le sang versé
donc c'est ça que j'ai beaucoup lu j'ai
beaucoup avantagé fait de recherche pour
comprendre ce qui se passait à l'époque
mais en fait c'est le cabinet de madame
guigou qui a donné une réponse je suis
pas sûr qu'elle était au courant je
crois pas qu'au ministre de la justice
il est au courant absolument toutes les
questions qui sont posées à l'assemblée
et de toutes les réponses qui sont au
sol mais j'aurai les cartes et ce à un
moment donné même la fédération des
anciens qui s'est un peu impliqué dans
sa même la fédération dijon le président
de la fédération à l'époque lit je crois
pas que madame thibout était au courant
au début après elle a suivi évidemment
il faut faire confiance à ses
conseillers sinon pourquoi on a
déconseillé donc elle a fait confiance à
ses conseillers elle a suivi un peu et
qu'on te raconter enfin de quoi il
s'agit évidemment elle a complètement
avec le point de vue c'est la peur je
partage tout à fait part toute assez ce
point de vue il ya il ya bien souvent
dans l'application de textes et autres
l'inertie de l'administration
et là vous avez des tas de portes à
franchir pour pouvoir arriver à prendre
une décision aujourd'hui je pense qu'il
est légitime que ce débat soit
d'actualité et de donner précisément de
faire en sorte qu'on puisse aller
beaucoup plus rapidement vers
cette possibilité aux légionnaires de te
dire si on est presque sur un malentendu
où je vous le rende je pense précisions
sur ce qu'a dit le député séquence est
lorsqu un légionnaire meurent au combat
ils restent étrangers il est aujourd'hui
encore aujourd'hui les 35 mille morts
pour la france sont sont des étrangers
morts pour la france ce sont des soldats
français mais qui servent à titre
étranger d'origine étrangers par contre
le blesser grâce à cette loi qui
reconnaît qu'ils étaient reconnaît la
légion étrangère en tant que décision
française parce que c'est pas l'armée
qui a décidé pour une légion c'est le
parlement c'est la nation qui se dote
d'une légion étrangère dès le temps de
paix et ce qui est important c'est que
le chou le cette loi permet à un blessé
de demander la nationalité c'est de çà
devient un droit
à partir du moment il la demande le
prono médiamétrie
le premier ministre l'a lui donnera
d'accord elle est toute la différence
qui est tué ses enfants parce qu'il peut
avoir des enfants quand même bien sûr
aucun droit alors si il dit son pupille
de la nation
quelqu'un qui est étranger qui meurt
pour la france ses enfants son pupille
de la nation et donc la loi permet de
prendre en charge ces enfants mineurs
d'accord situation cette fois ci on veut
dire deux mots un petit peu ce qu'est
l'histoire de ce corps nous ça vient la
légion étrangère j'ai lu que c'était lui
philippe qu'il avait créée qui avait
fédéré un petit peu rassembler toutes
les étrangers des armées dans la seul
corps qui s'appellerait joueurs
étrangers mais c'était pourquoi il faut
aussi on reprend l'histoire tous les
pays avaient des étrangers au service
service du roi au service du
gouvernement on connaît encore les gares
de suisse avait alors là exactement mais
ce sont des cordes étranger au service
d'un pays
et puis la france que se louer est
absolument sort le mercenaire alors non
le mercenaire c'est quelqu'un qui
s'engage pour de l'argent et pour
quelqu'un le légionnaire la légion
étrangère il s'engage pour la france
pour la légion étrangère y est et quel
quel que soit le métier qu'il fait il
n'est pas essoufflé il n'est pas le
payer pour aller au combat
il est payé il
fonctionnaire français employés par
l'état et non pas à la somme de
quelqu'un ou un mercenaire dès le début
conclut philippe ne décide c'est pas il
s'agit pas de rassembler simplement tous
ces soldats étrangers qui sont dans nos
armées et auxquels on fait on fait appel
donc à donner on avait pas d'étrangers
dans nos armées à cette époque là donc
on faisait appel à aux soldats français
ou bien à des étrangers pour une mission
particulière donc ça démarre en 1830 il
ya eu les débuts en algérie et puis la
légion étrangère a même été prêté à
l'espagne elle a d'ailleurs été décimée
là bas et elle est revenue en miettes
et puis on a reconstruit une légion
étrangère et elle dure depuis
aujourd'hui perché ce distinguo entre
mercenaires et les yeux verts ou le fait
aussi
oui c'est pas du tout c'est pas du tout
le même esprit vous savez ce sont des
combattants régulier les légionnaires ce
sont des vérités militaire des soldats
qui habite chose un cadre organisé le
mercenaire voilà c'est c'est la
privatisation de la guerre
le maire le mercenariat c'est le gars
qui est embauché pour faire un coup de
main pour ou simplement par une
entreprise un moment pour faire la
sécurité non c'est vraiment des choses
très différentes c'est au contraire
d'une certaine manière la légion je
pense qu'elle est presque la carnation
de ce show ce que sont les veillées les
institutions militaires où le corps est
très important c'est à dire mot fin de
l'esprit de corps est très important
donc je pense au contraire c'est plus
les sens de la chose militaire que le
mercenariat qui en est une
une décomposition alors je disais aussi
en prépare l'émission que pendant
longtemps la légion a été cantonné à
l'extérieur de la france n était pas au
bagne lommel et maintenant la maison
mère était pas au bail c'est à
l'extérieur parce qu'on se méfier de la
légion non mais l'été à sidi bel abbès
parce que parce que c'était la france
c'était c'était c'était en algérie et
puis quand l'un des camps à gérer
devenir dépendantes la légion a quitté
sidi bel abbès et est arrivé
mais sa vocation initiale c'est plutôt
d'intervenir sur les terrains extérieurs
c'était c'était il y avait l'armée
d'afrique l'armée d'orient la légion les
troupes françaises étaient beaucoup et
surtout engagé à l'extérieur mais elles
ont été engagées en 1914 se sont
remarquablement battu en 1940 elles se
sont battues 1942 bir-hakeim narvik donc
donc la légion étrangère
elle est au service de la france elle
regarde cas c'était l'anniversaire a
raflé sa 70e 79e
c'est une grande bataille gagnée par la
légion française par l'armée française
par l'armée française et avec beaucoup
de troupes de légion étrangère elle est
vivante étrangère en tire une grande
fierté mais c'est le déclic chez les
français c'est ce point de changement on
commence à gagner en 1942 ma victoire
épique contre les groupes de rebelles à
épices assis dans le désert et vous
parlez de l'aric parce que là aussi
c'est une des seules batailles gagnées
pendant 40 ans et bien sûr et la légion
avec les chasseurs alpins joue un rôle
primordial si vous voulez dans cette
bataille de narvik qu'est ce qui fait
que on se les fasciner par ce corps est
en même temps un petit peu peur c'est
c'est tout laisser tout le mythe
on est fasciné parce que ce sont des
jeunes des hommes d homme fascinant des
il n'y a pas un jour où quand je
rencontre les jeunes r je n'ai pas une
une nouvelle histoire une anecdote à 30
un truc phénoménal hier j'assistais à un
pot j'ai vu un cadeau de départ
légionnaires qui a fait un tableau du
rembrandt le type dans sa chambre la
nuit
il est peintre avec un talent fou j'ai
découvert ça y est et tous les jours
vous avez des des cultures des histoires
personnelles qui sont qui sont
fascinantes et l'inquiétude
chacun a un passé chaque légionnaire
s'il est venu à légion étrangère
j'ai dit qu'il était attiré par la
france mais mais c'est souvent un second
rebond il a commencé il est plus âgé que
soldat français à l'engagement
il a trois ans de plus et donc il a une
petite histoire qui peut être qui peut
être non pas criminel je ne prends pas
ses mots délictuelle c'est moi qui
sélectionne je ne prends pas criminel je
ne prends pas d'affaires de moeurs bon
quelqu'un peut avoir eu un petit après
avoir été
tire un voleur à la tire ou sait pas
encore quelle quelques affaires il
arrive il fait état de son passé si je
considère que c'est acceptable
je le langage l'armée d'ailleurs quand
on est arrivé avec un passé judiciaire
essayer de voir si le grain va voler une
mobylette à 16 ans et que il le dit et
puis j'ai dû me revoilà écouté il se
plie peut être engagée la licence qui
vous parle je parle pas de rats l'armée
de la légion et je vous parle pas d'un
gars qui a tué enfin braquage à main
armée ou tué sa belle soeur non mais le
graet a eu des petits soucis
inquiétude quand je parle d' inquiétudes
de fascination et d'inquiétude c'est
qu'on regarde souvent légionnaires le
longtemps regardé comme étant des gars
qui avaient fait des choses pas propre
avant dans une vie antérieure et que en
intégrant la légion eh bien ils
obtenaient une sorte de deuxième vie de
deuxième chance on oublié leur passé
intellectuelle régnante il arrive on
n'oublie pas leur passé je le mets entre
parenthèses
c'est à dire la loi m'y autorise c'est
le statut la légion étrangère le
candidat arrive me dit j'ai volé des
mobylettes je suis recherché dans mon
pays j'ai besoin d'être protégé et à ce
moment là il va bénéficier de ce qu'on
appelle une identité déclarée pendant le
temps qu'il a dont il a besoin même
s'ils sont nés de son état d'origine
c'est qu'il est là c'est ce qu'il a
commis le réclame alors vous lui donnez
pas la télé crochet the ideal à la
démarche de l'intéressée elle et elle
est personnelle et quand ils arrivent
son pays ne sait pas où il est donc moi
je vais l'accueillir
si je juge que ce qu'il a fait est
acceptable et qu'on va pouvoir en faire
un bon un bon légionnaires s'ils
demandent une identité d'emprunt
il va avoir cette identité qui va le
protéger en mettant entre parenthèse
parce que quand il sort de la légion il
retrouve sa vraie il retrouve ses
casseroles s'il en a eu et qui ne sont
pas réglés
donc les gens cependant peu c'est un peu
avant d'intégrer la légion vous dire ce
qu'il a fait obtenir qu'on mette ça fout
le mouchoir si je puis dire et le qui
lance le temps de la zec les identités
d'emprunt
faut il change de nom voilà qu'est ce
qui vous lie qui vous dise la vérité sur
ce qu'ils ont fait alors d'abord moi je
vérifie autant que je le peux et si je
m'aperçois que finalement et c'est un
criminel qu'à tuer quelque part à ce
moment là il m'a menti et la force de la
légion étrangère c'est celle du contrat
c'est pas moi qui vais les chercher ce
sont eux qui viennent et on leur dit
vous êtes volontaire il y en a plein qui
veulent on sélectionne est volontaire
ils disent oui il signe un contrat c'est
pas moi qui qu'il est l'heure que les
tire par la manche
ils s'engagent à dire la vérité et ils
savent que je les protège de ce qu'ils
m'ont dit si on découvre donc il est
autre chose
à ce moment là ils ont menti leur
contrat et casser la justice en occupe
donc je ne blanchit vais les remettre
à la justice de leur pays d'origine ils
ont menti mais s'ils ont menti je suis
puis je suis pas chargé découvrir donc
s'il ya un mandat international sais pas
quoi vous viendra chercher et l' enquête
pourrait tout à fait précis si vous
faites une enquête pour vérifier les
dires d'un légionnaire ou d'un candidat
la légion c'est à dire que vous allez
demander à son pays d'origine ce qu'il a
vraiment fait il ya plein il ya plein de
méthodes de méthode c'est un peu un peu
un peu technique mais je crois que dans
la technique de de l'accueil le fait de
poser les questions de manière
différente
un jour puis l'homme un bon ça prend un
petit peu de temps mais c'est important
parce que c'est c'est toute la
différence entre le soldat du régime
général et légionnaires c'est qu'il ya
une dimension de sécurité dont j'ai la
responsabilité donc moi je préfère bien
assurée on pose des questions de faire
de façon différente
et puis comme ils sont nombreux si j'ai
un doute donc je m'amuse pas à prendre
quelqu'un qui accorde baratine probable
que vous ne faites pas formellement de
contre-enquête sur le candidat la légion
dans son pays d'origine par exemple non
non non non ça c'est pas qu'est ce qu'on
dit alors des motivations des
légionnaires qui arrive
est-ce que c'est effectivement pour
échapper à la justice ou est ce que
c'est moi répandue que ça parce qu'on
l'a souvent vu comme ça je vous donne un
point de vue de journalistes je vois les
choses peut-être un peu différemment je
pense que dans l'histoire la légion
étrangère ça a été peut-être vrai il ya
cent ans disons il y avait peut-être des
régionales qui essayait de s'échapper je
sais pas d'être de jeux ou autres qu'on
retrouve dans les romans dans les films
il ya beaucoup des films sur la région
étrangères les choses vont changer
aujourd'hui justement parce que il ya
beaucoup de candidats et donc on peut
sélectionner on va pas prendre ce qu'ils
ont des casseroles derrière mais il ya
ce mythe il faut regarder aussi la bon
le bon côté des choses
il ya cette mythologie de la deuxième
chance y'a quelqu'un qui a fait une
bêtise et qui regrette de l'avoir fait
et sait très bien qu'il va porter cette
bêtise sur son dos toute sa vie s'il
veut changer s'il veut reprendre sa vie
être quelqu'un d'autre cela les jours
qui lui donne qu'il est dans cette
chance je me souviens avoir participé
avec justement mon mari l'a fait une
conférence dans une école avec des
enfants un peu
enfin qui avait fait des bêtises qui
valait un peu de partout
l'idée de la deuxième chance l'a dit bon
vous avez fait une bêtise ça peut vous
poursuivre toute votre vie mais vous
pouvez de commencer la légion vous donne
une deuxième chance ça c'est très
important si vous voulez devenir
quelqu'un d'autre est là les gens
peuvent bel les aider devenir quelqu'un
d'autre et secours c'est le pourcentage
de ceux qui rentrent chez vous qui aurez
effectivement fait une bêtise comme on
le vit non je crois que celui qui n'a
jamais pêché non mélissa et de mobile
c'est difficile de faire des
statistiques comme ça mais il est clair
que je retourne je vous ai dit je prends
pas des criminels
mais je recrute pas au diocèse
voyez ce que je veux dire c'est pas un
petit séminaire c'est des gars qui ont
toujours si ça passe et voilà quels
qu'ils soient qui petit peut-être le
rêve qui peut être une difficulté un
échec ou mais cette notion de deuxième
chance dans vous parler elle et elle est
forte et je reçois dans mon bureau tous
les légionnaires qui font plus de 25 ans
au moment de leur départ
donc j'ai cet entretien très privilégié
en tête à tête
qu'est-ce que tu retiens tu de tes 20 30
40 ans la semaine dernière 40 ans la
légion et gd des mots magiques des gars
qui me disent la légion ce n'aurait pas
été là j'aurais été une ordure
là les gens aient pas été là je ne
serais pas ce que je suis aujourd'hui un
autre m'a dit j'ai tout donné à la
légion si c'était à refaire je tiendrai
encore plus si c'est pas magique
non mais je rêve focal des gens qu'on me
dit pas c est que c'est peut-être aussi
pour ça que dès qu'il se passait quelque
chose dans un village près d'un cran
légionnaires on avait vite fait
d'accuser la légion et de voir la main
du légionnaire serrières ça aussi c'est
aussi ce qui fait peur et moi je me
souviens en afrique en côte d'ivoire et
bien l'arrivée avec mon régiment le chef
des rebelles est venu me voir en disant
ah didon là attention là donc il ya une
crédibilité et cette peur cette peur
qu'ils à quillan qu'il qui ne suscite
est accompagné aussi d'une crédibilité
des combattants qui nous est très
bénéfique
on fait peur à son adversaire battu le
genre de l'universel je pense qu'il ya
au monde
aucune
troupes militaires paramilitaires aucune
armée régulière ou non qui lorsqu'on lui
dit en face de vous vous avez la légion
dort bien voilà il ya vraiment s'amuser
aux dépens des turcs ont été tués
c'est une à c'est un soldat c'est
ceinture c'est bassiste bat son plein et
tu as mis son il ya cette mythologie ou
sur bon sens du terme
c'est vraiment une armée mythique c'est
à dire que dans le monde entier les gens
la connaissent assez bien des chercheurs
des bad boys
oui bah écoutez ci-haut diocèse oui
c'est vrai ouais c'est pas la garde des
enfants qui est en même temps en même
temps vous savez c'est pas une âme ouais
c'est pas c'est pas une bande de voyous
lâcher c'est extrêmement disciplinés et
organisés
c'est ça qui est fascinant oui et le
jeune voyou du quartier le gars il n'a
pas envie qu'on emmerde pour parler
clairement il a envie de faire son
business avec ses copains dans son coin
la démarche pour aller la légion c'est
le contraire de ça le gars pendant cinq
ans il a plus de vie à lui
il a plus de vie à lui cinq ans et la
durée d'un contrat c'est la durée nier
il va on va lui demander de faire des
choses qui sont pas drôles
l'entraînement de base du légionnaire
c'est quand même pas de tenir les murs
au bas de combat de sa cité pourrie
c'est pas du tout ça c'est pas du tout
ça donc c'est vraiment difficile sans
les voix dans la boue partout et c'est
vraiment difficile notamment qui
réduirait discipline et sénateurs est ce
que vous en aviez peur de ces
légionnaires à côté de vous quand vous
les côtoyer c'était quoi il avait la
réputation d'être des mauvais garçons
surtout pas avoir dit la vérité mais je
dis la vérité parce que il nous appelait
tenté de la réguler de layoule hier que
tu t'occupes pas ça c'est notre problème
ça à yakh et un code interne bien et
qu'ils avaient des choses à un respect
total si vous voulez de par rapport à ce
qu'ils appellent nous le
les régiments classique que nous étions
et qu'elle faisait partie total à
réguler les souffert c'est pas tout cas
pas de ses problèmes et une solidarité
exceptionnelle
il y avait un mythe aussi du légionnaire
même quand on était de la réunion les
regarder en disant c'est des
légionnaires a bien entendu il y aussi
ce qui était impressionnant chez eux par
exemple lorsque vous étiez dans
différentes conditions
c'était de voir le silence l'ordre la
façon avec laquelle il se déployait la
façon avec laquelle ils intérêt et ça
c'est un acquis 7 c'est tout
l'entraînement qu'ils avaient c'est mais
à quel prix parce que on parle aussi de
l'entraînement qui est très dur on parle
de et de ce silence qui est obtenu avec
des gens qui sont pas a priori très
disciplinée qui sont plutôt des pour
certains des voyous etc
on l'obtient commença en allant au delà
de certaines comment dire certaines
limites
je vous dire que laboral la discipline
david rey la discipline à la légion
c'est une nécessité absolue qui démarre
d'un point d'un point clé c'est que le
légionnaire ne parle pas français au
début il faut lui apprendre le français
est donc dans toutes les phases de sa
vie pour se lever pour se coucher pour
prendre les repas pour aller il faut lui
donner des ordres lui apprendre à le
faire et donc il ya un processus de une
pédagogie de la répétition dans la vie
courante puisque la vie à la légion
c'est un cours de français il arrive y
parle pas à la fin de son contrat lui
permettant à celui-ci
alors si quelqu'un ou non je n'apprends
pas assez vite j'ai eu déjà sinon il y
eut des bizutages c'est pas comme si on
parlait ça qu'on tournait mal
des fioles lourde à la légion c'est un
viol j'ai pas je juge j'en sais rien il
peut y avoir des choses aux dans une
communauté humaine et je suis là pour me
battre contre cela mais est ce que je
dis c'est quand quand il démarre donc on
fait ses cours de français cette
pédagogie qui construit progressivement
la communauté et qui fait qu'après ils
se retrouvent il est passé de la rigueur
dans la dans la vie de la chambre et à
la rigueur sur le terrain une discipline
qui est effectivement forte une
discipline de feu au combat que l'on
voit les génère il raffole pas y tire
sur ce qu'ils voient et c'est tout ça
parce que c'est une nécessité d'avoir
tous ces
angers qui parlent le même langage qui
est celui du chef et donc quand le chef
donne un ordre
il est exécuté d'accord mais il ya
utiliser des incidents il ya eu quand
même des moments on se dit que
l'entraînement va très très loin enfin
je rêve pas il ya eu il ya eu des îles
il ya eu de 6h10 toi il ya eu des sales
histoires dans la région il n'y a pas de
doute
alors faut fouiller réfléchir la légion
a peut-être qu à une époque et peut-être
parce que c'est dans sa nature
cette tentation de vivre sur elle-même
de 2-2-0 ce que disait le sénateur ce
sont deux affaires les seydoux les
régler à carnon rbk comme ça on
objectivement effectivement c'est aussi
l'héritage des guerres coloniales de
conflit très très particulier voilà mais
ça ça existe
en tout cas ça existe et il faut
effectivement combattre ça la légion
c'est l'armée française et l'armée
française c'est l'armé d'un état de
droit et on veut pas y faire n'importe
quoi
et donc si des officiers ou des gens s'y
comporte ou des légionnaires entre 6
comportement ils doivent être
sanctionnés
mais bon il ya des cas il ya je me
souviens à quelques années à djibouti un
entraînement qui tourne mal
l'officier a fini en prison y financer
ça c'est pas une zone de non droit la
légion c'est une chose que l'on contrôle
nous regardons autour de nous l'homme
qui est chargé il en reste vous parlez
de code il y en a qu'un c'est le code
d'honneur l'armée terre en adopter ainsi
similaire quelques années après et moi
ce que je fais c'est je fais appliquer
aux légionnaires la loi française et je
l'amène progressivement à l'autonomie
dans la loi française
lorsque quelqu'un un lieutenant un
commandement d'evian
c'est à dire c'est un officier formé par
l'armée française qui pète les plombs et
qui est sanctionné c'est même pas moins
qui le sanctionne ainsi le chef
d'état-major c'est le ministre parce que
si ce nous et la justice bien sûr nous
sommes bien ce sera dommage de loin la
loi laver son linge sale en famille je
parle clairement à tous très clairement
à une époque à une époque c'était dans
l'armée française en général on essayait
de régler les affaires
aujourd'hui c'est lors du temps réel
c'est l'heure du temps réel et de la
transparence
et quand il se passe quelque chose le
compte rendu est immédiat le chef d'état
major de l'armée terre il a tous les
matins les deux trois affaires qui a pu
la voir dans l'armée française en
général à la légion étrangère en
particulier en guyane il y à toutes les
semaines des contrôles de 2 au 3e
régiment étranger d'infanterie d'usagé
de stupéfiants le ce régiment rencontre
dès qu'il coince quelqu'un qui a utilisé
de la drogue pour proposer autant de
désertion des défections au sein de
l'armée dans les premiers mois il y en a
beaucoup qui s'en vont quand même passer
parce que l'entraînement justement est
trop dur alger des trop sévère vous
parlez de réversion du légionnaire est
ce que pour quelqu'un qui est venu de
votre bout du monde
déserter c'est pas finalement petit coup
de blues je décide de rentrer à la
maison le le schéma mental du
légionnaire n'est pas celui du soldat
français
il est venu servir un pays qui n'est pas
le sien et quelquefois et ben il se
trompe on se dit qu'il s'est trompé et
rentre à la maison et y aurait beaucoup
voilà il y en a il a toujours trop nos
magasins fait que le jury sur une année
il y en a entre 150 et 200 sur combien
de surin sur un mets un petit millier et
beaucoup c'est les gens oui mais le bon
l'armée terre 10 15% on est on est là il
ya un peu plus de légionnaires qui qui
déserte dans les six premiers mois que
dans le régime général
et puis un petit peu moins sur les six
mois qui suivent donc que ceux à 30 %
ça vous paraît normal qu effectivement
lié ces défections l'âge après lamballe
bien sûr le blues le blues
on appelle à phare du cafard qui bien
que ne va rien arrive il arrive que les
années avec affaire le soin d'en satan
c'est qu'il rentre à la maison je le
voyais un cancer du sein
alors le temps passe mais il ya aussi un
point sur lequel on s'interroge beaucoup
c'est le statut même du légionnaire dont
on dit qu'il faut utiliser en tout cas
il a une identité déclarée qui ne vaut
rien à l'extérieur qui lui permet pas
d'exister de reconnaître ses enfants
s'il en a de pouvoir contracter acheter
une maison enfin il est il est mineur
civilement
elle avait exactement mais je vais vous
dire quand ils arrivent c'est lui qui
demande à ce qu'on l'accueille et qu'on
lui donne une identité je ne peux lui
donner qu'une identité militaire
donc il va avoir une carte militaire il
va pouvoir aller au cinéma il va pouvoir
se déplacer prendre le train mais la
banque
il ne peut pas justifier de son identité
pour ouvrir un compte
il ne peut pas faire un emprunt et il ne
peut pas souscrire à acheter avoir une
assurance une voiture et keita il peut
se marier il peut pas se leurrer c'est
un corps dont une à la tentation
il ne peut pas se marier quand il est
sous identité déclarée autrement je
fabrique moi-même une famille du moyen
atlas une égale donc quand il sera quand
sa situation sera régularisée au bout de
six mois un assist au rythme de il peut
le décider s'il a un souci qui veut
rester soudés euro/dollar et véritable
dans des médiations moi il y en a plein
si vous voulez il ya ça fait partie du
mythe aujourd'hui sur 7000 et je n'ai
rien à peu près 15 cents qui sont sous
identité déclaré don dont 800 qui sont
dans la procédure initiale est-ce que
c'est toi pour façon pour dire les
choses clairement de les garder quand
même sous la main tous ces gestionnaires
mais son et moi je chante bêtement
dépendant de la légion je cherche à
accéder au plus vite cette procédure
parce que je ne leur interdit pas de
faire tout ça c'est la loi française qui
ne les autorisent pas à aller dans une
banque avec une identité qui n'est pas
reconnu donc il faut pas voir ça comme
des privations je suis chargé de faire
respecter la loi comme on disait tout à
l'heure
et dès qu'ils sont régularisés on essaye
de faire ça au plus vite il recouvre les
droits d'un citoyen alors on va écouter
un petit peu ce que dit le général cool
on m'attend dans ce troisième extrait de
votre documentaire et on va vite
éclairer un petit peu l'avenir en
s'interrogeant sur l'utilité de cette
unité aujourd'hui dans une armée qui est
devenue maintenant professionnel on
écoute général coulon
moi j'ai des amis qui sont
caporaux-chefs
et j'ai des amis qui sont gênés reviens
sur mes remarques et la légion
essentiellement à une colonne vertébrale
qui est son corps sous-officier
incomparable la france n'a que deux
exceptions pour moi elle ad'abord
l'académie française est la deuxième à
contestable c'est la légion étrangère
pourquoi parce que aucune nation monde
qu'a voulu nous copier une la russie
quand je les ai connus j'étais lieu sous
lieutenant et lieutenants
or les leçons que j'ai reçus s'éteindre
je n'ai jamais vu je n'ai jamais eu à
régler un problème à mon sens
d'insuffisance de ces gens là sur le
terrain ils ont toujours été témoin
exemple j'ai bien vu cette image du
légionnaire qui nettoie son fameux képi
blanc qui est l'une des nains des des
éléments de reconnaissance du
légionnaire avec dans les défilés la
barbe le tablier de sapeur lâche le
palente ça c'est inconvenant codefi 14
juillet qui plaît beaucoup
ça va ya tout un mythe comme ça qui fait
que les légionnaires sont partiellement
applaudi alors l'académie française a
priori la remet pas en question la
légion est ce que aujourd'hui avec une
armée moderne avec des corps qui sont a
priori aussi performant on a des
commandos-marine on a des cheveux
pourquoi on a des parachutistes on a
tout ça est ce qu ont encore besoin
d'avoir des légionnaires aujourd'hui
évidemment je crois quand même le
sénateur je pèche pas personnellement je
pense que oui arthur fry font partie
d'une composante des forces françaises
avec leurs particularismes avec leur
expérience vous avez des régiments
la fente ring marine vous avez certain
nombre de régiments qui forment des
commandos qui forme qui ont de
l'expérience qu'ils ont également des
entraînements très poussée ceci la
légion étrangère fait partie c'est
toulon c'était des professionnels et une
époque où l'armée on avait très peu plus
qu'une armée de construction dont il y
avait deux classes étaient des
volontaires d appeler et c'est
maintenant l'armée à les professionnels
elle est l aide professionnelle mais
pour moi pour six étrangers mais pour la
bonne et simple raison enfin pour ce qui
me concerne qui a cette image
indispensable je dis bien c'est une
attractivité de notre pays des gens
vient dans la légion étrangère ils
viennent en france ils viennent dans nos
unités et je crois que c'est un plus
pour notre peau tendre pour notre armée
qui sont un petit peu cru aussi on se
dit quelquefois ça coûte moins cher
politiquement dallest envoyé des
étrangers au combat se faire tuer c'est
moins embêtant conçoit des français
n'ont alors est-ce que c'est à ça que
sert la légion chacun peut avoir la
lecture qui veut du rôle que le 2 qui
donne à la légion étrangère
ce qui est clair c'est que d'abord ce
sont des soldats de qualité des
volontaires qui viennent renforcer les
rangs puisque ça rajoute j'allais dire
clé-en-main 7000 soldats dont la
répétition dans la très performant et ça
c'est un atout majeur
1 le je pense que le dans l'histoire de
france ça s'est vu à de nombreuses
reprises notamment en nommant de kolwezi
président il envoyer la légion parce que
voilà une image hop on fait pas on voit
ce régiment la politiquement d'envoyer
la légion que l'on revient sur trouve
certes si c'est clairement le carré mais
c'est ya 30 ans
oui à l'époque d'ailleurs ça ne veut pas
être le régiment de légion qui devait
partir savez un régiment d'infanterie de
marine de par des parachutistes et
qu'ils ont assez mal vécue parce qu'on
leur a dit ben non vous partez pas c'est
la légion qui va donc à l'époque c'est
vrai dans cette armée de coup au fond
cette armée qui était une armée de
conscription une armée très nationale
dans un peu héritière de demont de la
révolution enfin voir de toutes ces
affaires
en revanche aujourd'hui non je crois que
l'armée larmes les jeux relationnelles
ou à la has et c'est simplement un corps
un peu particulier et puis quand on
regarde ce qui se passe dans les autres
armées internationales on voit bien que
beaucoup de pays sont intéressés par ce
modèle parce que beaucoup de pays ont
des difficultés de recrutement
c'est parce que ce n'est pas vraiment le
cas de la france ça pourrait arriver et
donc par les américains recrutent
beaucoup de gens issus d'amérique
centrale où
qui sont sur le territoire américain
leur disons venez passé cinq ans chez
nous et puis vous serez américain à la
sortie donc les anglais aussi ont
recruté des gens dans le commonwealth
sont les gours kaki et recrutait au
népal ouais beaucoup de gens étaient les
espagnols recrute des gens dans les pays
latino-américains bon beaucoup de gens
essaient de faire d'autre au fond c'est
un modèle assez moderne pour des plus
logiques la rspo d'être une critique et
celle d' que des mains qui émanait de
madame le refus dans le rapport qu'elle
a fait en 2010 sur la légion où elle
disait elle parlait de fabrication de
sans papiers de non-droit elle disait
que les pratiques anciennes de
l'institution légion était dépassé est
ce que il ya ne serait-ce que sur le
statut du légionnaire des choses à
revoir maintenant pour que on évolue
vers une normalisation de la situation
mais je crois que ce rapport comme comme
d'autres parce qu'il y est il y en a il
y en a toute une succession nous nous on
nous ont permis de nous regarder avec un
oeil neuf il ya beaucoup de choses qui
ont été qui ont occulté évolué notamment
notamment sur la régularisation de
situation militaire qu'on essaye de
faire au plus vite à une époque tout le
monde arrivait avait une identité
déclarée maintenant seuls ceux qui en
ont besoin l'on est le temps pendant le
temps le plus court possible donc la
légion étrangère
elle avance dans ce dans ce domaine là
on ne cultive pas des archaïsmes pour le
pelé pour paulo pour le plaisir
ça reste si vous voulez une troupe de
grande qualité et une intégration de
volontaires par l'effort si j'avais un
souhait mais ce serait celui de dire que
le légionnaire qui au bout de ces cinq
ans dix ans souhaite la nationalité
française qui lui soit facilité
l'obtention de cette tabouret sur
l'appareil d'air berlin finalement je
vais vous dire c'est que je le souhaite
c'est le cas et ce que je souhaite à
bien entendu ou délivrer un certificat
de bonne conduite
celui ci doit être délivrée justement
avec pour que l'appréciation sens enfin
quelconque et que des gars qui ont
pendant 5 ans 10 ans 15 ans servi nos
couleurs mérite que l'on y ont les mêmes
droits que n'importe quel étranger ide
en france aux régularisations ce qui
peut devenir français après les délais
habituels
ça pourra même aller un peu plus vite
lorsqu'il quitte légion étrangère parce
que je veux lui remettre le certificat
de bonne conduite alors certains
m'avaient dit c'est discrétionnaire
la légion fait sa sauce pardonnez moi
c'est ma responsabilité je donne le
certificat de bonne conduite à celui qui
a bien servi et celui qui est déserteurs
qui n'est pas là mais je peux pas lui
donner
donc aujourd'hui je la tribu quasiment à
tout le monde sauf aux déserteurs et aux
quelques cas qui en mon âme et
conscience ne verrez pas ne mérite pas
ils n'ont ils ont ils ont trahi leurs
paroles ils n'ont pas été des bons
légionnaires et il termine mal donc je
ne leur donne pas ça ne les empêche
d'ailleurs pas de devenir français en
respectant les procédures normales sa
plaque jeunes et leur bande votre appui
je ne dois pas le coup de pouce si tous
merci beaucoup merci de nous avoir un
petit peu fait comprendre un peu mieux
ce qu'était cette légion étrangère qui a
encore une fois appelé toujours autant à
chaque fois qu'elle défile sur les
champs elysées comme on le voit donc là
à tous les 14 juillet voilà c'était le
dernier débat de la saison merci à eux
résident à face qui les a tous préparait
d'ailleurs très fatigué poster à écrire
ou la comprend merci de nous avoir suivi
on se retrouve bien sûr à la rentrée et
je voulais sur public sénat